créer du feu c'est facile mais comment
on pourrait faire la même chose avec du
froid
si tu veux te faire un barbecue en
pleine forêt tu peux frotter dubois plus
pour te faire une glace ou un sorbet
comment tu ferais même dans le monde
animal s'il ya bien des animaux capables
de produire des étincelles et des
liquides bouillant il n'y a pas l'air
d'exister d'équivalent contraire
pourtant dans nos imaginaires il existe
des dragons cracheurs de glace des
pistolets cryogénique des princesses qui
créent des châteaux polaire et bien sûr
des super héros capable de se battre
avec du froid
alors on va vous expliquer avec la
science comment ça serait possible
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait un super héros
ou un dragon pour pouvoir tout gelé sur
son passage
je dois vous prévenir puisqu'on va
parler dément cette vidéo est sponsorisé
par les posters magnétique displayed on
a des offres spéciales pour vous en fin
de vidéo ici en fait le pouvoir du froid
existait déjà dans la nature c'est moi
vous avez quelque chose on vous a menti
en fait le monde vivant s'est créé du
froid même nous les humains la preuve
quand il fait 40 degrés dehors votre
corps arrive à se maintenir à 37 degrés
pourtant on n'a pas de réserve de
glaçons en nous alors comment fait-on et
bien la réponse se trouve justement sous
vos aisselles ou plutôt sur la totalité
de votre corps vous vous refroidit c'est
grâce à la transpiration votre peau va
générer de petites gouttelettes d'eau
qui en réalité ne refroidissent rien du
tout si ça marche c'est grâce au
phénomène physique qui va se produire
juste après phénomène qui va pouvoir
justement servir à notre super héros
vous allez voir alors comment la
transpiration nous refroidit d'autres
petites gouttelettes de sueur vu qu'il
fait chaud elle va vouloir s'évaporer
sauf que pour passer de l'état liquide à
l'état gazeux pour faire une transition
de phase
il faut de l'énergie de l'énergie pour
changer l'état de la matière et cette
énergie elle va vous la voler et donc
vous refroidir et suit votre
transpiration c'est en réalité retirer
plein de petites gouttelettes qui aurait
bien aimé vous donner le grand frisson
ce principe vous pouvez l'observer avec
une petite expérience rigolote à faire
prenez une bouteille d'eau tiède en
boule et là dans une serviette humide
tiède mettez la au soleil au chaud et
vous verrez la bouteille va refroidir
l'eau s'évapore de la serviette va
réduire la température en volant de
l'énergie à la bouteille d'eau tiède
maintenant est ce que notre super héros
pour utiliser cette méthode pour geler
ses ennemis après sion température et
humidité ambiante bat pas vraiment dans
la nature un autre moyen qui semble
efficace pour créer le froid c'est le
vent
le vent souffle en hiver tu le vois bien
et frigorifiés ce procédé même utilisé
par des objets pour refroidir plus
rapidement vos boissons vous mettez
cette espèce de ventilo dans votre frigo
et votre coca est gelée en quelques
minutes
mais tout ça c'est du vent ça ne
refroidit pas vraiment en réalité autour
de chaque objet et même de vous même
il ya une sorte de couche de chaleur qui
vous isole de la température ambiante
cette couche de chaleur vous la
produisez vous même en réchauffant une
portion de l'air qui vous entourent le
vent va simplement la balayer ça vous
force alors à recommencer le processus
ce qui vous coûte de l'énergie et donc
vous refroidit à quoi s'ajoute
l'évaporation accéléré de votre sueur et
donc encore plus de froid
c'est pour ça qu'en hiver sans vent ça
va et quand il ya du vent fou horrible
malheureusement votre super héros pourra
souffler un vent de 10 mille kilomètres
heure s'il fait 30 degrés dehors la
température ne bougera pas en vérité le
seul être humain que j'ai vu être
capable de générer de la glace ce sont
certaines plantes qui font en hiver ce
qu'on appelle des fleurs de glace ou
pensez probablement que c'est juste la
rosée qui s'est gelé autour de la fleur
mais non c'est bien les liquides dans la
planque qui forment ces structures de
glace mais pour que ça marche il faut
bien qu'ils passent très froid en
extérieur rien qui puisse être utilisé
par un super-héros aucun processus
biologiques ne semble être au diable
alors essayons de voir du côté des
machines quelle méthode on pourrait
utiliser pour avoir des pouvoirs de
glace comment la science arrive-t-elle à
créer du froid comment cette mystérieuse
boîte carrée dans votre cuisine
arrive-t-elle a gelé des trucs quand
j'étais petit je pensais que le frigo
était plein d'azoté liquide dans les
films c'est un peu une substance magique
qui est capable de tout gelé
si vous plongez votre malade d'en
vouloir sortait en glaçon
malheureusement tout ça est un mensonge
déjà plongé votre main dans l'azoté
liquide est certes dangereux mais vous
n'allez pas jolie en un instant la
couche de chaleur autour de votre main
vous isolera temporairement du liquide
mais pour moi la grande révélation de
mon enfance c'est quand je me suis rendu
compte que l'azoté liquide
en fait
ces deux là zot un gaz normal qui
constitue même 80% de l'air que vous
respirez
or vous l'avez remarqué mais les autres
qui vous entourent ne vous gêne pas pour
que le gaz deviennent liquide il faut
d'abord de compresser et c'est ce qui
nous ramène à notre réfrigérateur
comment fait-il de la glace s'il
n'existe aucune substance magique
capable de créer du froid le
fonctionnement d'afrique où est en fait
assez simple il consiste à créer du show
je vous explique dans le bac à glaçons
derrière le plastique il ya du gaz qui
circule un gaz qui a comme propriété de
pouvoir passer à l'état liquide sous
pression raisonnable ce gaz donc va être
comprimées échauffés derrière ton frigo
ce qui va transformer le gaz en liquide
un liquide qui est donc due à la
compression en gros les atomes sont tous
collés entre eux ça va remonter tout
autre ton frigo et c'est là que la magie
opère
là il ya un petit orifice qui va le
laisser passer qu'un tout petit peu du
liquide à liquide qui à cause du
changement brutal de pression va
redevenir un gaz mais vous le savez
maintenant comme pour la transpiration
pour passer de l'état liquide à l'état
gazeux
il faut voler de l'énergie et cette
énergie elle va le trouver dans l'air
ambiant du frigo ce principe vous pouvez
le vérifier avec votre déodorants ou un
nettoyeur de clavier vous pouvez
carrément gelée de l'eau avec ici vous
avez du froid creal en bout lors de la
décompression du gaz comme votre frigo
mais aussi à l'intérieur par évaporation
du liquide comprimé on retrouve toujours
le même principe du frigo à
l'évaporation et c'est justement comme
ça qu'on fabrique l'azoté liquide dont
parlait au début en prend de l'air
ambiant t on la compresse énormément 30
fois plus que ce qui était nécessaire
dans ton frigo
ça reste à la portée de monsieur tout le
monde il ya même des tuto pour fabriquer
son propre azote liquide maison
[Musique]
ce qui nous permet de dire qu'un super
héros de glace a en fait une capacité de
compression extrême de l'air ambiante
jusqu'à atteindre un stade liquide il le
projet très ensuite sur son adversaire
pour lui capté toute sa chaleur et en
faire un simple glaçons il existe
cependant une deuxième méthode pour
créer facilement du froid des mélanges
chimiques
il y en a un très facile d'accès pour
notre expérience et pour ça il vous
suffit juste d'avoir un glaçon et du sel
avec ça on va être capable de faire
passer le glaçon de 0 degré à moins 20
degrés celsius
comment ça se fait comme vous le savez
le sel et la glace saint patron c'est
pour ça qu'on en jette sur les routes
gelées pour les dégeler sauf qu'on est
d'accord
le sel n'est pas chaud alors qu'est ce
qui se passe en fait au niveau
moléculaire lésions sel vont briser
l'arrangement des cristaux de glace
ils vont [ __ ] le boxon et ils vont
briser l'eau qui était devenue solide et
du coup pas une baroudeuse mien liquide
encore une fois vous savez ce qui se
passe quand la matière change d'état
elle a besoin de voler de l'énergie
c'est pour ça que les glaçons vont
fondre alors même que l'eau est à moins
20 degrés sans regeler c'est grâce à ce
phénomène qu'on faisait des sorbet au
moyen-âge d'ailleurs des chevaliers à la
lourde armure occitane ne pouvait se
taper un petit mikko calme en attendant
la castagne en sciences est ce qu'on
appelle une réaction endothermique l'exo
thermique ray de la chaleur landau
thermie en retire créant ainsi du froid
et nombreux sont les réactions chimiques
qui permettent d'obtenir cet effet par
exemple en mélangeant du citron et du
bicarbonate de soude ou tout simplement
de l'eau et du nitrate d'ammonium
mais la réaction la plus folle et celle
entre l'hydroxyde de baryum avec du trio
sanad d'ammonium tu mélange de poudre et
tu peux descendre jusqu'à moins 30
degrés on pourrait imaginer notre super
héros avec des glandes capable de
produire deux substances qui mélangeait
pourrait geler l'adversaire une
troisième méthode existe et c'est celle
que vous pouvez retrouver dans la vidéo
de la machine à faire des glaces aux
huîtres du deuil qu'à regarder avec un
simple circuit électronique fait maison
ils arrivent à se faire son sorbet on
appelle ça un module de pelletier n'ya
pas d'appareillage bizarre exotique à
acheter juste de quoi faire du courant
et de plaques de céramique entre les
deux plaques ya rien d'autre que des
semi conducteurs très basique dn ep semi
conducteurs le mot fait peur mais dans
notre cas ici c'est juste du silicium
mélanger soit avec des atomes qui donne
des électrons soit qui en veulent
quand on met du courant là dedans il va
y avoir des échanges d'électrons entre
les semi conducteurs certains vont
perdre d'autres en gagner le principe
ici c'est de mettre ceux qui perdent
leurs électrons d'un seul côté de sorte
à ce qu'ils veulent l'énergie à la
plaque en céramique
résultat elle refroidit un tel module
permet d'atteindre des températures
théorique allant jusqu'à moins 100
degrés celsius
ça lui permettrait de refroidir
rapidement un liquide qui projetteraient
sur l'ennemi quelque chose qui reste
liquide à très basse température comme à
température ambiante le trip tower de
chlore ou le führer hydrogène seraient
de bons candidats s'ils n'étaient pas
extrêmement dangereux à manipuler
comment atteindre le zéro absolu le zéro
absolu
c'est la température ultime de l'univers
400 millions de fois plus froid que ton
frigo il est fixé à moins 273,15 degrés
celsius c'est presque 80 degrés de moins
que l'azoté liquide qui est le gaz
compressé courant le plus fois autant
vous dire qu'on va pas vraiment
atteindre cette température avec des
méthodes conventionnelles pour réussir
cet exploit on doit comprendre la nature
même du concept de température à savoir
l'agitation d'atom entre un café froid
et un café chaud c'est juste vos atom
qui libre un peu plus même à moins de
150 degrés celsius ça bouge encore il
faudrait donc trouver un moyen de
totalement arrêter ce mouvement ou du
moins s'en approcher car réduire le
mouvement d'un atome
quand vers zéro sans jamais vraiment
atteindre le zéro serait paradoxalement
infinie c'est comme ça que la plus
froides températures jamais atteintes
dans l'univers s'est passé sur terre ou
du moins pas loin le 11 septembre dans
les ss la nasa a réussi à refroidir un
gaz de rubidium à un pico qu'ils dînent
au dessus du zéro absolu
vous le voyez à l'écran c'est beaucoup
de zéros après la virgule
mais alors comment ont-ils fait on est
très loin de ce qui se passe dans ton
frigo et si on a utilisé des lasers
ouais enfin les lasers c'est pas supposé
être chaud ici le laser n'apporte pas
vraiment d'énergie aux atom il influe
plutôt sur leurs déplacements
en fait les photos envoyées par les
lasers vont entrer en contact avec les
atomes pour les faire ralentir au
maximum et donc baisser la température
pour exploiter cette stratégie des plus
roublarde on utilise les lasers par six
se poser perpendiculairement dans des
pièces magnétique servant à garder tous
les atomes au centre d'une chambre à
vide à la croisée des chemins on observe
une
en ralentissant considérablement la
vitesse des atomes un peu comme de la
glue au sol une sorte de mélasse optique
ces procédés serait même exploitables
sur des larges objet peut-être qu'un
jour ou pour écrire une pièce pleine de
lasers pour vous gelez instantanément
notre super héros a donc besoin d'une
chose ralentir les atomes autour de lui
et les projeter sur son adversaire
ah s'il sera capable de geler tous qui
l'entourent vous attendez pas non plus à
faire des miracles
n'allez pas faire des icebergs
l'humidité dans l'air ambiant c'est
moins de 10 grammes par mètre cube ce
qui vous entoure ne suffit même pas à
remplir une bouteille d'eau donc pour
faire des châteaux de la saint raphaël
loire se lever tôt mais plutôt que de
détruire notre super héros on devrait
plutôt utiliser son pouvoir pour sauver
l'humanité s'approcher du zéro absolu
c'est pouvoir débloquer des capacités
incroyables dans le domaine des
supraconducteurs ou pour avoir une
énergie quasi illimité faire léviter
d'être en créer des champs
électromagnétiques
ça serait probablement le pouvoir léman
terre le plus utile à l'humanité
et puisqu'on parle dément et de rêves
que diriez-vous d'utiliser le magnétisme
pour avoir une chambre ultra stylée
décorée de posters displayed et oui
merci à displayed avoir sponsorisé cette
vidéo c'est un concept génial de poster
mais en métal plus besoin de faire des
trous partout il suffit de l'accrocher
avec des pastilles aimanté et dada le
truc va pas bouger pas se plier et passe
humidifié c'est vraiment le top
et oubliez les posters avec des taxis
jaunes sur fond de ville grise ils ont
deux milliers de modèles différents pour
tous les fans et pour tous les goûts
on vous a même préparé notre petite
sélection à découvrir en commentaire de
cette vidéo on a aussi pour vous un lien
d'affiliation de -27 % sur 1 à 2 10
payent moins 37 % pour 3 c'est jusqu'au
14 octobre donc foncé il reste plus
beaucoup de temps
montrez moi sur twitter vos chambres
ultra stylée avec de lourds displayed
merci voilà on a donc notre super héros
capable de créer du froid soit avec des
lasers soit en comprimant de l'air soit
en projetant des mélanges chimiques plus
simplement en ayant déjà stocké un gaz à
très basse température comme l'azoté
liquide
c'est sûr que c'est un peu plus
contraignant que se faire mordre par une
araignée mais vous savez maintenant
comment créer du froid j'espère que la
vidéo vous a plu hésitez pas à vous
abonner puis à suivre et peut-être à
découvrir à un prochain pouvoirs de
super-héros expliqué par la science
merci à tous les amis merci aux monteurs
et et à sky pour l'écriture de la vidéo
allez ciao
[Musique]
c'est pas possible il faut au moins -